[Music]
okay so
today we're going to look at
some of the older kentucky joe
there's ten of these but they're not the
same as the
the later kentai joes that were in the
weapons scrolls
when i learned these they weren't really
presented as a systematic thing
with numbers we're going to use numbers
in
cypher sentence hardback
aikido book volume 2.
some of them also
evolved into the
later koopie joe
okay this is number one now from here
i'm
[Music]
difficult for him to pick the sword up
so easily so moving straight
down as he steps around and makes a
small step across pick up his
arm to control it
and then it will finish with a thrust
strike down
control
we're using the joke here and then
thrust
down
this is the second one i raised joe he
steps in with a car
i strike the head
move back and he steps with a thrust i
need to make sure i'm clear of his sword
so i'm going to step across and strike
and adjust the foot
if i if i try and do this it won't move
there's a risk that he can catch my arm
here so it's safer to
split this down into two
on the
red times
he's quite fast
from that side
so
this movement
here
and slowing down
quite a lot
in the
book it says
strike the face and then you really
should be
striking it ahead to make it safe but
that's gonna
make you pause
so here
step
i'm trying to strike
with the tip of this rather than just
give it a sort of leg
that's right so let's go straight into
his roots
and then here
[Music]
it's number three so i i
open up he steps into strike
coming here
come here and control his move
and step out on the strike
it's quite similar to the
seventh hole
older soul partner practice
when you go down that side
there's more controlling in that one so
on here control
and i need to step out
to get this kind of distance
so it's almost like a
[Music]
the throws work better if he's still
trying to cut than if he's
goes into sort of a passive
just standing there moment
but
sparing the fall on this floor i think
so i'm moving
here and be really careful with this
because it's pain it's a dangerous move
potentially so i blended with his
movement in here now this is
potentially quite dangerous so i need to
make sure i'm going to miss his face so
if you're practicing this you've got to
be careful
i've
taken joe through here move to the side
as she's cutting down
this thing
[Music]
okay this to number five
sequential movements i actually
hit him three times because this is a
blunt instrument it's not like a sword
you can
do significant damage
you know necessarily in one go
strike the wrist
taking the hat over
here
hey
all right
[Music]
i'm just leaning forward into that i
just flash that in front when i move out
of the way his cut continues down
bring this across between his arms
now he's going to raise up for a cut so
he raises
into the fall into the throat okay
again
the problem with doing this is some
people are very completely catholic when
they try and sort
it's better if they
[Music]
okay number seven
kind of similar to the
second one
it's number eight i mean opposite joe
starts so open up
step in here
bring the joe out here
it's just about put the weight on
you whip it away from it
can be an unpleasant fall so if you're
doing that you'll make sure you keep
your back ahead off the ground
[Music]
number nine i mean
the opposite starts again
so he
i open up he comes in for a cut
and i strike the wrist
here now you can
strike the sword down but it leads you a
little bit far away strike the wrist and
then bring this
in here
and throw
it like a rotatory turkey hose in the
sort of
moon very powerful throat because you're
linked
with the joe makes the body movement
and the
unification move very easy
[Music]
this is number ten open up your cuts
strike building
um
okay so that's the 10 older kentucky joe
uh park practices at some point we'll
probably get around to doing more up to
date ones and
it could be joe okay thanks for watching
hope you found this interesting